gigi's playhouse held its first ever 5k  and one mile walk today the non-profit  wants to change the way the world views  down syndrome the gg fit acceptance  challenge took place at cornerstone park  in the southeast valley organizers say  all the profits from that event are  going to a special cause  all of the  proceeds from this event are going to a  bill build believe in our build campaign  which is to bring a brick and mortar to  the las vegas community so we can  provide free programs to persons with  down syndrome of all ages  for more information on how you can get  involved or donate just head to our  website 8newsnow.com